follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram
hello everyone welcome to the Lange
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's video is the third installment
in the mystery languages series maybe
you've seen mystery languages 1 & 2 if
not you can find the right here but
here's how it works I'll play you a
sample of a language and then I'll show
you a written sample of the language and
you can make an educated guess as to
what that language is and don't worry if
you can't guess the exact language
correctly the important thing is that
you tell us your guesses and your reason
for your guesses in the comments down
below and that will start a lot of
interesting discussions so let's get
right into the first language please
listen yum is presenta a booyah Novus
incorporations Anna Kendrick de
corridors
Cayden todos de Marcia's D chose toon
esposa temperature sisi eko nitrogen a
que es un exempt respondent rover
activity' t proposed desperado soos
Bustos now let's see some written
samples of that language Gwang Costa
show this means how much is this only
salah babu this means where is the
toilet
badly miss Opoku boxes flow this means
speak more slowly please kamu podría
salir de she's plow this means could you
write it please so what language is it
[Music]
the language is Catalan a Romance
language spoken mostly in eastern Spain
as well as in Andorra and in part of
France
if you guessed Spanish or Portuguese or
another Romance language then you're not
too far off in fact Catalan has 85%
lexical similarity with Spanish but the
two are only partly mutually
intelligible Catalan is part of the ox
eternal romance subfamily along with
Occitan it's always interesting to take
a look at a Romance language that you're
not too familiar with because you might
see some features of one Romance
language and some different features
from another Romance language if we look
at this sentence again podría looks like
the Spanish word for could this word sqa
seems kind of like a clear in French or
screw Verde in Italian which means to
write and this phrase see use plough
seems like si vous plait in French so
you can see why some people say that
learning to Romance languages helps you
understand a fair bit of the others at
least in writing okay on to the next
language please listen
and again let's have a look at some
written samples in demand I left this
means how are you when said to a male
Selita why work in decibel onion
this means pleased to meet you symma
mano this means what is your name when
said to a male it is so ok yet note this
means where are you from so what
language is it the language is Amharic
Amharic is a language spoken in Ethiopia
by around 22 million people it's a
member of the Semitic language family
meaning that it's related to Arabic and
Hebrew but it's not intelligible with
those languages I've studied Hebrew and
Arabic in the past but I can't
understand I'm hark at all but there are
a couple of cognates I can see in these
written samples like the word for name
sim in Arabic the word is ism and in
Hebrew it's Shem here in Amharic simha
is your name with the suffix F being a
possessive pronoun in Arabic you'd say
is Mac and in Hebrew you'd say simcha
also Hmong is the word for what which
might be related to the Arabic word Matt
and the Hebrew word mom okay on to the
next language please listen
Divakar Segel part Asik are you until
puberty yet but today are an article
Munna birth of a party so the name i
atill gear indicator paper eita of Amaka
body on average under pura very Charlie
Gill aren't able over them we are given
a more critical part us all again given
the Euro minivan Kelly what does a
practical Ginter count over a putana and
again let's see some written samples of
this language onl aparted a rhombus and
o shop this means pleased to meet you
one goes under you ready this means
where are you from angela party room
analyzed chip
this means long time no see in EFI annum
forever this means have a good journey
so what language is it
it's the tamil language tamil is a
language spoken in southern India as
well as in Sri Lanka as well as by Tamil
communities overseas and places like
Malaysia and Singapore Tamil is a
Dravidian language which is unrelated to
the indo-european languages spoken in
northern India Tamil has a long literary
history reaching back to around 2600
years ago the Tamil script is an abugida
meaning a script in which consonants and
vowels are written together as units
which can't be separated come to think
of it the amharic script that we had a
glance at earlier is also an abugida
well I hope you had fun guessing today's
mystery languages be sure to leave your
guesses and your reasons for your
guesses in the comments down below and
I'm sure that that will start lots of
interesting discussions be sure to
follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram and I'd like to say thank
you to all of my patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen for their continuous monthly
pledges thank you very much and have a
nice day
[Music]
you
[Music]